how to train your dragon
started a new interest in these mythical
creatures and they brought them into the
spotlight into our homes
and into our hearts we have done
previous videos on the biggest dragons
from the franchise
and also a size comparison video on them
but now in this video we shall
do a top 10 most powerful dragon ranking
video
and we will include the various ones
seen in the three animated movies
and their animated series as well so
remember to hit that subscribe button
and like button to be a part of the
minekeel family so let's get down to it
number 10 the fireworm queen the
fireworm queen lays thousands of eggs in
her lifetime
and builds a massive nest made of a
flammable gel known as fire comb
to house her many thousands of eggs and
the only known one the firebomb queen
lives on fireworm island
in the base of a dormant volcano it
looks similar to
the average fireworm in appearance but
it has some differences
that make it stand out from the rest for
one it is huge in size
and queens are very powerful and they're
bright and have napalm type fire breaths
that emit small firework like particles
and they are quite powerful that's why
they are on number 10.
number nine the crimson gold gutter
although gore gutters have impressive
sets of antlers and axe shaped tails
they are gentle and and they appear to
be gentle giants and like to be left in
peace
in battle however they have the ability
to spew molten lava onto their antlers
before ramming opponents with their
fiery force
the crimson gold gutter is a large
boulder class dragon that first appeared
in how to train your dragon
the hidden world due to their huge size
and bulk
these dragons possess an immense level
of strength and power with its powerful
build and magma powers
it has earned the rank of number nine
8 the typhoon meringue typhoon meringues
possess immense strength
which combined with their large size and
weight make them one of the most
strongest non-alpha dragons known to
vikings
they can stop forest fires with the
flaps of their massive wings
and also uproot trees just by walking
through them typhoon ranks are capable
of
surviving crashing into multiple
obstacles without much injury
and they are very durable and are
capable of enduring multiple
shots and physical attacks from other
dragons such as gronckles and hideous
zipplebacks
and they are even fast enough even fast
enough to be capable of keeping up with
the night furies
and maybe they are even faster than them
number 7 shell fire it is an enormous
deep sea dweller with crustacean
attributes
the shell fire glides through the ocean
at incredible speeds and tows the dragon
hunter battleship
bolted to its back the shell fire glides
through the ocean
with fast and incredible speeds and
shrug off's attacks with its durable
armor
its carapace delivering devastation with
its protruding horns which are very big
and very long as a titan wing the
shellfire is one of the largest dragons
to appear in the series
and its armored carapace is so durable
and resistant that it enables
it to endear almost anything even blows
from the submarippa
its natural enemy number six the summer
ripper
characters the kraken sea serpents
for centuries frightened sailors have
told tales of a beast that could turn
the very oceans against them
but this is the work of the submaripper
a very big dragon
a tidal class dragon the summer ripper
has the ability to create whirlpools by
sucking the nearby water into its mouth
it is powerful enough to suck down large
ships or dragons that are around the
size
of squadrons and powerful enough to pull
dragons that are above the water
although it is smaller than a shell fire
it seems to be more aggressive towards
it
and seem to be on the offensive against
the bigger one
number five the red death it is secretly
responsible for centuries of human and
dragon conflict
the red death alongside its subspecies
the purple death and the green death
it has a commanding presence to order
other dragons to raid nearby villages
and bring in a constant supply of food
from its layer deep within the corona
of an active volcano their state and
wing reigns supreme
all dragons have a blind spot except for
this one as it has six
eyes at around 400 feet long this is the
second biggest dragon in the series
and the animated films and one of the
most powerful
with an 8 palm 5 breath and a powerful
build it takes the fifth spot
here and yes there are even more
powerful dragons on this list
number four vulca's bewildered bees
walker's beautiful the beast is a very
old
and honorable bewl the beast dragon a
title class leviathan
and has been a noble and diligent dragon
long enough to create a fan kingdom
of his own to provide a heavenly
sanctuary to many local dragons in
stress
and they worship him as their king and
alpha like all bewildered bees
his power comes from being the biggest
of them all and his sharp touch as well
as his icy breath
that can stop a rap death coal in its
tracks
it might seem gentle and caring but it
also has a very
rough and tough attitude and sight and
that only the next dragon could beat
number three the drago's bewildered
beast in comparison to vulca's
bewildered beasts this individual is
darker
and looks very menacing tyrannical and
violent
additionally he seems restless and
always enraged and gloomy
he is also slightly larger than vulka's
bewildered bees understandably
his behaviors are unfriendly and
destructive because he was always kept
in confinement and
always in pain and searching for
violence to fight other dragons
measuring 520 feet long and a bit bigger
than walker's dragon
he was also raised as a weapon and only
knew pain and violence
which made him stronger than the
previous one whom he stabbed to death
with his armored dust
number 2 the night fury or toothless
the night fury was once considered to be
one of the most mysterious
and fearsome species of dragons the
night fury is the fastest smartest and
rarest of the known species of dragons
as toothless is the last known member of
his species
although being small and not really that
physically powerful as compared to the
other big ones on this list
he has many other powers though and that
made
even the previous wildebeest dragos to
bow down to him as the new alpha
this includes the dive bombing attacks
purple plasma flames
becoming stealthy and cloak itself to
become invisible
it is also able to use echolocation and
roam around in the dark
and an alpha dominance display and all
that on a 26 feet long dragon
and number one spot goes to the
screaming death
but the most powerful of them all has to
be the one that even toothless
couldn't even manage to scratch but just
annoy
this is the screaming death a very
mutated version of the whispering death
dragon
with no fear of sunlight and being a
dragon of gigantic proportions around
200 to 300 feet long
the screaming death possessed incredible
strength which when combined with its
weight
makes it one of the strongest dragons
around in the franchise
it can also shoot numerous fireballs in
fossil session like a machine gun
and destroy everything around it as well
as shoot sharp spikes and spines
at moving targets this dragon is super
fast
has very high endurance and stamina and
the most powerful skin of any dragon
with even toothless plasma attacks doing
no harm to it
and to top it all it is very intelligent
so yep
numero uno the screaming death
and so with that we come to the end of
this video and we hope you liked it and
if you have another list
of your own then do put it down in the
comments section
and it might just get pinned so take a
minute to like this video for support
and click the subscribe button to be a
part of the mind cue family
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates
on your phones when we publish videos on
monsters
and dragons and godzilla vs scoring
dissection videos
right here on mind cue take care fam